was speaking of um horny stuff
yeah what's up brother you heard about a
twitch stream or misbehaving
oh is this no it sounds like it but it's
not it's for real
no i didn't no what happened to her this
is so funny
all right so people on twitch have been
suspended for
all kinds of innocuous [ __ ]
you know people got suspended for
playing clips
of valenti you know and she didn't even
get suspended
for the whole thing yeah i know this
this young woman
all right she she
apparently didn't uh
swap her stream key because she's a cam
girl i guess
but she also no
so she gets on twitch
just turns around and just
shows that [ __ ] showing oh really
just whole yeah she showed the starfish
just straight up
that's how she started the stream with
her ass i i don't know the full
you know you know i was about to make a
joke about
whatever but yeah apparently she i i
i don't wanna you know
i don't wanna spread misinformation but
my understanding was that at some point
in the stream
she just flipped around pulled
underwater to the side and
just just shown hole
i was gonna say that's a pretty it was a
pretty hardcore way to start a stream
out
it's not it wouldn't be good to do that
at the beginning though because not
everyone's tuned in you got to let it
but that's what i'm saying but but she
could be going somewhere
way crazier you know it's true you don't
know what she does on her camera
[ __ ] that could be the way that she
starts maybe that's the foreplay
so she got a three-day ban three days
for showing [ __ ] this is back
spec what people have been been for like
a month
for playing a [ __ ] drake song bro
uh some some like anonymous twitch
person hit up
that video game reporter slasher
and dm wrote him an email was like uh
your coverage of the company is very
concerning
and like it was like you know not really
a threat but it's kind of like vague
threat okay
you know and someone says switch yeah
that was anonymous yeah but it's gonna
be crazy
yeah he tweeted about it but he was like
oh yeah that's that's the issue guys my
reporting
maybe you know not the way you guys
handle [ __ ] yeah
i don't know man twitch has gotten i
think a little too comfortable
yeah i think they're they're ripe for uh
someone to come through and
and [ __ ] it up now you think so i think
i think
twitch streamers would [ __ ] bail if
mixer came
now they just they they came a little
too early mixer came now
streamers were bailing left and right
because what everyone's just sick of the
yeah just like the inconsistent
moderation
it's so clearly like you know moderators
are
it just depends who you get you know
they're like the [ __ ] dmv
yeah you know like so sometimes they're
good sometimes they're bad
yeah so you know
i think i think you know uh oh i think
they've had passed some
some tos term they added where you could
no longer
see who a person was following
because i think a bunch of twitch mods
were getting outed
for ninety percent of who they followed
were just
you know women with
like titties really basically yeah
oh my god so the whole thing is just
biased towards yeah
towards that yeah it's just these
[ __ ] these is these horn dogs that
just you know
he showed hole on stream oh she showed
hole on stream wow wow
well technically we have to ban you we
don't want to technically
what i can let you back into the
platform the rules say hey
listen the rules say we gotta do
something about this
but they're not my if it was my rules
i'd say more whole
not less that's so funny that she got
banned for
three days she's literally showing her
[ __ ] and again i don't know if that's
true or not but it's so no that's true
so she did show her [ __ ] she showed
her [ __ ] and she got banned for three
days
three days three days people have been
bad for weeks
for less for like
scratching their balls you know what i'm
saying
yeah but how nice were their [ __ ]
no but like that's crazy
yeah yeah we still that wow
mm-hmm we still don't know what
dr disrespect got banned for but it
couldn't have been bad is that right
showing your [ __ ] on stream is pretty
much
the most that you can do to get banned
forever
yeah i don't know i don't yeah it's kind
of crazy
what the [ __ ] could a doc have done you
know did he like have someone murdered
off camera
yeah i don't know during the stream he
had someone murdered off camera during
the stream that's why he got banned he
was sending texts to his contract killer
yeah hey man do it now
she was really misbehaving yeah there
you go
there you go that day
confirmed man all the mods are coomers
man
[Music]
coomers oh man that's still crazy
the thing that's crazy to me is
that's what the internet's for it
buttholes
buttholes and degeneracy and like it's
like supposed to be your
second life mm-hmm why what
i don't like this future where people
are getting banned for showing butthole
that's the whole point of the internet
it's to be a totally
you know it's not on twitch
no [ __ ] twitch is for good clean fun
ugh they're fun for the whole family who
is running that company now
i just you know i just i just want
everyone to be able to freely show hole
and say
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and come you know what i
mean yeah and still get coca-cola ads
still get a coca-cola why doesn't
coca-cola want to advertise on butthole
videos
why not coke
good for your whole yeah
you know it's refreshing after showing
your hole on camera that's the whole
this should be the whole ada should be
misbehaving turns the camera she's like
hey boys boy i'm tired
oh you know what i could go for a nice
cold coca-cola
yeah and then the theme song plays
freshen up your start
coca-cola good after showing your
[ __ ] on stream
you know what the best thing is after
showing
your a-hole a whole coke a whole
oh my hole is bubbling again better get
back to the stream
freshen up your stuff
nothing better after showing your hole
in a whole coke dude
corporate oh my god big big brand
sponsored porn videos
like today i will be shoving this entire
refreshing
diet coke up my [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
it's got a light on it the brand she
sends it in for feedback to bring it
back the can was a little turned before
you shoved it in or as you were putting
it into your ass we couldn't really see
the diet
coke logo so if you could reshoot that
part
dude it's a [ __ ] mentos commercial
just picture the song playing
mentos she takes the stick of mentos she
looks at it smiles
she shoves it all the way in her [ __ ]
then she's walking down the street
and a businessman is is running he's
like man
and a businessman is running he's got a
thing of coffee he
he drinks it and he's like i have a
meeting in 10 minutes
and the porn star is like she holds up
her finger it's not even a porn star
it's just a woman
okay holds up her finger and he smiles
they have a mutual understanding
and she just [ __ ] flips both her legs
up and shoots those mentos
right out of her [ __ ] into his mouth
he's like
they high five mentos
he goes to his meeting there we go
with a big clean smile mentos the fresh
maker
that's juveniles hill i'm sorry uh now
i'm just thinking about
some girl farting out mentos into diet
coke
[Laughter]
that has to be a thing right
[Laughter]
no man [ __ ] she puts both into her
butthole and sees how long she can last
no
she [ __ ] puts a butt plug in and then
she just shoots off like a
[ __ ] coke bottles
dude perfect
oh
[Laughter]
oh my god you're really getting them in
there yeah jeez i didn't know you had
someone
and they stick a two liter in there and
just yeah you squash it and then
plug it no yeah
then she takes a football shaped butt
plug
all right are you ready are you ready
and it's a dude running long
with his [ __ ] arms up he's like
alright go
[Laughter]
arms like a goal post and then he
catches it in his mouth
dude perfect